it's time for the launching from esco a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
wats company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
team Chronos cope mister william
bradford huie editor of the American
mercury and mr. Donald I Rogers an
editor of the New York Herald Tribune
our distinguished guest for this evening
is mr. Harry a McDonald chairman of the
reconstruction Finance Corporation the
opinions expressed are necessarily those
of the speakers just McDonald you of
course are one of the world's biggest
bankers as head of the reconstruction
Finance Corporation our viewers are
always interested in how to borrow money
and tonight why if we'd like you to tell
us something about the RFC which I
believe is now about 20 years old now
sir as the first question why is the
United States government in the business
of lending money why is the government
of the United States and the business of
loaning money si I think that's a very
has a very simple answer because there's
a need for it all right now the RFC was
founded at 1932 I believe in mr.
Hoover's administration that's correct
is me that is true ow what was its
reason for being when it was founded at
the time the RFC was first initiated and
created it was a stopgap piece of
legislation designed to take effect an
aide in a faltering economy well did it
do that job of helping the American
helping this country over the depression
or I think it did very definitely and
then during the second war what was its
function then of course during the
second war perhaps no other government
agency received as many extraordinary
duties as did the RFC the president
through everything that couldn't
otherwise be put somewhere into the RFC
building defense plants and assuring
supplies of short materials and that
sort of thing quite definitely and
credit no lesson so you're saying that
during the Depression you you let
millions of dollars sustaining American
business and helping us through the
depression then during the war you were
you aided the government with defense
plants and so forth now today what is
the principal justification for the RFC
well it seems to me in the type of
economy we have today where small
businesses put to a greater strain
perhaps credit wise than ever before and
where other AB will I say I've calls
upon business beyond the normal credit
give of the banking institutions I say
that's what the RFC comes in do you do
many things but essentially today you at
you at point to the fact that you make a
lot of loans to small businesses perhaps
the most valuable contribution to the
country now I think if there were ever
any time in our country's history when
this thing called free enterprise which
is largely when finally in the analyzed
called small business if there is every
time when that small business needed
help credit wise it needs it today in
other words sir you replace or supplant
the banking industry in the in the local
communities I don't think we do i think
that the banking institutions in banking
credit in the local community is just as
necessary if not more so than ever watch
then why do not these small businesses
get their loans from their local banks
that's that's quite a question
small business cannot always be taken
care of by the local banks first because
of credit restrictions of the pond upon
the banks themselves are loaning
restrictions and second because perhaps
the credit of the institution requiring
the Lowell or applying for the loan
wouldn't exactly satisfy the back in
other words sir you take over what the
bank would consider a bad risk well you
can call it a bad risk if you like we
don't we don't give credit to
institutions where they can receive
credit from any other institution in
other words we only give credit where
banking credit is not available so
that's so you won't compete with the
banks that's true and may I make that
clear so it depend on misunderstanding
in other words we have many times
participate with a local bank and
extending credit to a local to an
institution to our to an applicant and
do banks refer the applicants to you Oh
quite definitely now what would be the
procedure for a small businessman to get
a loan from the RFC well just as simple
as some as he can make it if he hasn't
credit available to him through his
local bank and if he is in need of
credit if it's a local institution
employing local people and for a good
public purpose credit being refused
otherwise he applies the RFC do you
finance new ideas or schemes or or do
you have to finance going businesses
well mr. Rogers I'm glad you asked that
question because that's so often put up
to us and that's so often advanced as an
argument against the RFC we don't
finance that schemes and pet theories we
finance going businesses do you make the
businesses put up capital to back their
loan or do they have to have collateral
of any type well you're assuming when
you say to do that we make the
businesses put up we don't finance new
businesses as such if an old business is
in need of a financial loan
Circle they make them put up collateral
of kilometres available now mr.
macdonald you say that the RFC over its
period of 20 years has rendered a
variety of valuable services to the
American people now this of course is a
is a bureau and you are a bureaucrat now
what does this all of this service cost
the american taxpayers mr. Huey I salute
your expression of bureaucrat that's
perhaps a general term applied I happen
to be a businessman of long standing and
I'm in serving my government now as best
I can are you asked the question of what
does this cost our government to render
this service to the American people
namely what does the RFC cost SC up to
date it hasn't cost them anything they
made a profit you mean the American
people over 20 years have had this
advantage from the government and we've
still and it's a profitable Enterprise
for us I mean just that what do you pay
your salaries of it something like 3,000
people who work for you do you pay them
out of profits or are they paid out of
general appropriations mr. Hewitt I can
explain that in a Bernie in a very few
words I think since the inception of the
RFC which goes back to the Hoover
administration of 1932 when the
government created the RFC with a with a
structure at corporate structure 100
million dollars with giving of course to
it loaning capacity the RFC has returned
in the form of profits from the RFC
activities alone I think I to a break
off period of March of 31st 252 some 622
millions of dollars out of which has
been paid back to the Treasury over half
of it
the other half being retained in the
corporation for working capital you mean
that this is an enterprise that the
American people make money off we get
these benefits and we still make money
and it doesn't cost us anything if you
put it that way that's exactly true
that's after all expenses of salaries
charge-offs bad loans losses and
everything that's after all expenses
well the RFC has been distinguished more
recently not for its profitable
operation servant for shall we call it
skulduggery there has been evidence
presented in Congress of graft and
influence in the RFC which was before
your administration now has that been
cleaned up well mr. Rogers of course
that that's very easy question to answer
I could answer was one very short word
and that is yes well could a senator
could a senator call you now and ask for
some influence say friend of mine Don
Rogers in New York once alone and I'd
like to have it go through could he call
me and ask to go through he could call
it ask perhaps but if he were to insist
that would be something different I
haven't yet experienced that thrill of
having a senator and sister Lauren go
through you get a lot of telephone calls
from members of Congress I assume i
think that as long as there is a
congress that'll always be constituents
there always be an honest interest in
constituents and i can't blame any
congressman or any senator for taking an
honest interest in his constituent but
so long as he keeps it on that basis
what about from the White House do you
occasion I get a call from some of the
people over there I'm very happy to tell
you that the president when he asked me
to take this I was going to say onerous
situation he told me he said you will
run that and I don't want me to do with
it and that's it so you're assuring our
viewers that the mink coat era at the
RFC has come to an end I don't know
anything about a mink oh dear I just
know that at the present time it's a
it's a clue business well when the RFC
was established sir it was more or less
on an experimental basis we have gone
through two or three very serious
periods in our economic history which
made it necessary for our FC to be in
existence is the experiment over is the
RFC going to last is it going to be in
business from here on in I would say
this and I'm asked that question so
often in fact ever where I go when will
the RFC ceased to be an entity one unit
cease to be I think and this is not a
partisan question at all this is a
common-sense question reasoned out by
virtue of the economy in which we exist
the RFC can serve a purpose in our
economy so long as it's well
administered well thank you very much
mr. McDonald after all the unfavorable
publicity and misunderstanding it's good
to have the policies and programs of the
RFC clarified for us thank you to
trigger the editorial board for this
edition of the lawn gene conosco was
mister william bradford huie and mr.
Donald I Rogers our distinguished guest
was mr. Harry a McDonald chairman of the
reconstruction Finance Corporation